[Music]
spider-man into the spider-verse is one
of the best comic book movies of 2018
and as always there's a lot to unpack
from both its ending and post-credits
see throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the movie and its final
act there will of course be heavy
spoilers so fuel yet to see the film or
don't want to know its ending then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel where I ruin it
so you don't have to ok so into the
spider-verse
opens with Peter Parker as he runs
through the origin it's pretty clear
that this is the same spider-man from
the Raimi films so it's a nice nod to
give the story some background from the
get-go we then cut to Miles Morales our
main protagonist he lives in Brooklyn
with his mother and policeman father and
it's a creative and streetwise kid loved
by the locals Myles is highly
intelligent which has caused him to move
schools this is strained the
relationship with his father who wants
what's best for miles but Myles wants to
go back to his old school where his
friends are throughout the film we see
that Myles feels out of place in school
and it's very difficult for him to fit
in amongst the elite the movie also
showcases how Myles looks up to his
uncle Aaron and how spending time with
him is the reason for his street smarts
his uncle Aaron wants Myles to express
himself so he takes them to a secret
spot to spray paint this is where we are
introduced to the alchemax and Myles his
life is sent spiraling out of control as
he's bitten bias by their Myles stumbles
into a fight between spider-man and
kingpin slash Green Goblin and the
Prowler and Peter notices that Myles is
special like him Peter dies in this
fight leaving Myles to promise to stop
kingpin as the villain opens a pole into
another dimension kingpin wants to open
this portal because Vanessa and his son
are dead so he wants to take other
versions of them from the multiverse
this is when miles meets Peter Parker
from the 6-1-6 universe who was an older
and out-of-shape spider-man he is trying
to get back home and Myles agrees to
help him in exchange for training we're
then introduced to several other
versions of spider-man including
spider-man hua Penny Parker and
they devised a plan to get home and
miles promises to destroy the machine
after their return journey the story
takes a turn for the worst when the
spider gang fight kingpins men and the
Prowler is killed and shown to be miles
as uncle Aaron this is Miles his Uncle
Ben moment and Myles learns that with
great power comes great responsibility
Aaron worked for kingpin but refused to
kill miles so kingpin killed him instead
this scene also showcases that Myles is
not ready to take on kingpin and despite
a family decide that they will do it
without him however Peter inspires Myles
to take a leap of faith and shows him
that anyone can be spider-man this sets
up the final act of the movie where
milestones despite a family in a fight
to get home and stop the kingpin opening
another portal and destroying New York
at the film's end they win after one
hell of a battle that nearly kills Myles
and all of the characters get to return
to their respective worlds it's a
brilliant origin story that Peter flee
sets a miles per eyes as the new
spider-man to me this story is about how
anyone can be spider-man it shows an
origin for all of the spider family and
sets up that we can all be the hero
should we just take a leap of faith it's
a really powerful message that reminds
us that we all have the ability to do
the right thing no matter the odds I
absolutely love this meaning behind the
movie Myles his father who was
originally distrusting of spider-man 2
gains a new respect for him after he
saves the city and Myles shares this
with his father after realizing how
difficult his job actually is and how he
just wants the best for his son
in the post-credits scene of into the
spider-verse
we joined spider-man 2099 played by none
other than Oscar Isaac there were rumors
that Isaac was cast in the film over a
year ago and it's great to see him
behind the first Latin Spiderman in his
New York apartment 2099 uses a web sling
and gadget that allows him to hurl
across the universe to earth 66 earth 66
like its namesake as the 1967 cartoon
that aired during the 60s on CBS the
show recently saw a resurgence with a
number of memes so it's brilliant to see
every surface year as 2099 arrives at
Earth 67 he bumps into that universes
spider-man and the two Spidey's recreate
one of the show's most famous means fans
will obviously lap this up and I adored
seeing the meme play out on the big
screen it's clear that Sony have some
big plans for the expansion of the
spider-verse
and I can't wait to see what they are so
what are your thoughts on the spider-man
into the spider-verse film did you enjoy
the movie and where does it rank amongst
the other comic book films of 2018 for
you comment below and let me know and if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and check out my breakdown of this
week's other big comic book revelation
the flash this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I'd been definition you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]